it's 7:00 in the morning
and there is a party raging downstairs
this is Dave Reagan a morning movement
where people are coming to dance their
faces off get sweaty all completely
sober
and it's Tuesday so they're going to
their deaths in about two hours
you walk down into a dark basement it is
a huge energy bomb are you getting this
- what it's a lot of crazy people you
walk out of there you're like is it 3/8
no it's actually 9 a.m. you have the
entire day in front of you
Bay Breakers a pop-up party so where and
when the next event will be held is only
revealed to email subscribers shortly
beforehand
once they announce the next party you
can buy a ticket for $25 but there are
usually only about 300 per sale started
as an experiment that we think we
thought we didn't think anyone going to
come and then everyone showed up I'm a
dermatologist by day and I'm a morning
dancer by morning how many are doctor
just got done with the overnight 12-hour
shift up in the Bronx starting my
morning this way ending my night I'm
actually a buyer for guilt are you going
to work today yes to be at work at night
day breaker started in New York in 2013
around the same time an unrelated group
in London started their own sunrise
party called Morning Glory belt both
groups have already expanded overseas
and are planning even more parties in
cities around the globe the economic
work and they're not allowed us to
continue grow in a labor of love but
it's a stable one ever just like you
know what I'll try it once I'll wake up
the morning try it once you know but
then it's like they come and they want
to come back again they want to like
again I know you're like yo screw that
7:00 a.m. oh there's no way I'm gonna do
it
try it try it you will become a dick